so hello everybody i am with dr paula
boddington uh dr
paula is a moral philosopher you have
seen her on my channel before we talked
about ai
and we had such a great conversation we
thought it would definitely be worth to
continue
thinking about ai but she's also a
an expert on the ethical quandaries
relating to medicine
and uh in terms of biological issues
let's say and so
right now with uh with all these things
going on i posted about this monkey man
and then there's also the whole thing
about ai which is swirling and
cobit of course so we thought that we
would talk about this in relation to
storytelling and the kind of stories we
tell
about uh about the things we do in the
world as humans
this is jonathan pajot welcome to the
symbolic world
so dr paula thank you for coming again
i'm really happy
i know a lot of people really enjoyed
our first conversation um
and so you you had something you wanted
to start with so let's go with that and
then we'll
we'll see where it leads us yeah hi it's
really good to talk to you again
so yes so yesterday yesterday i also i
should maybe start off by saying happy
st george's day
it's important to play today okay great
yes wonderful
yeah so yes yesterday on twitter i saw
that somebody had put up
that meme from um a conference of
the vatican using the kind of creation
of adam meme which i wish it was a meme
it was an advertisement like if it had
only been a meme it would have been
better
an advert for two hands touching like
and even one had even
one side had even got the kind of like
you know how adam's really
limp wristed yep like and then and then
um surgical gloves touching and
and and you reacted quite strongly to
that
well i i just it just shows you just how
clueless people are about what things
refer to
you know the fact that they would put
out an image like that is so
problematic on so many levels and it's
such a misunderstanding of
of of of what things like i said what
things refer to
and so i just couldn't believe that they
used this as an advertisement for
a conference about about medicine and
covid and all of this it's it's quite
mad
yeah yeah so i i i'd be really
interested to talk to you about
about when you said it's it's so wrong
on so many levels
what those levels are but also because
it's such a common meme in
ai it's used so often to illustrate that
you know illustrate ai in various ways
and if you put ai creation
meme into a search engine you'll get
you'll get dozens and dozens and dozens
of images images on different themes so
sometimes it's like a robot hand um
sometimes it's like a kind of digital
hand
sometimes there's sometimes those colors
and quite often actually there's a
little spark like an electric spark
between the fingers
that's as if instead of being
god breathed life into adam there's it's
a spark of electricity
um yeah there's so many images like that
and
i just think it's really interesting how
well if there's so much possibilities
there's so much
possibility in terms of how the hands
are transposed
the way it makes it really easy to swap
one to the other
yeah i mean it's really in terms of
maybe i i just wanna because i i said
that on twitter maybe i could i should
help people understand why it's such a
problem first of all
then we can see why the ai
meme would appear as well there are many
reasons why it's a problem and there was
there were so many first of all that
image is problematic in the first
sense because theologically already
there's a difficulty in that image
because
it because of the whole bearded god
figure
and then adam and you know the touching
of the fingers which is just a very
strange
way of under creation in in scripture is
manifested through
breath uh and so you know the image
it's it's remaining in breath and so
it's word speaking the word
creation into the world and then also
breathing but it's also light as well so
the i mean actually gets it better
probably with that little spark that you
said in the middle
because there's also the sense that
creation happens through light because
light reveals form to us reveals the
unity of things to us
but in that in that meme they in that
advertising they put gloves on the two
which even if you understand that this
like the touching
is what created adam it's a i always i
was thinking like what if god used
contraceptives is basically what they're
trying to
yes it was it's like okay what a strange
idea
and then then all these these these me
these funny things started going through
my mind it's like
oh so they they basically want to
reintroduce veils in the
in the tradition like what are they do
are they putting a separation like an
absolute
separation between god and man so just
this misunderstanding and there's also
the strange
thing which is that you know they wanted
to be multi-ethnic but they didn't
really
realize that they had like a white man
with with the hand of god and then would
look like a black woman
with like the the hand of adam being
limp and then the other one
you know they don't it's like they so
don't understand they're the only
the things they're referencing to that
they're it's exploding all these
directions that they obviously didn't
intend
um but it's also because they don't
understand the they don't understand the
problem of the moment which is why
they're even daring to go in this
direction they don't understand
what how it is that the the the
covid and the separation of people and
this idea of separating yourselves from
others
what it means and especially what it
means in church all of these things
are are things we're struggling with and
so you can try to
just like you can try to gloss over it
and pretend it's not there but then it
ends up coming back even in your own
advertisements you know even if
even as you're trying to advertise the
coping measures
you end up suggesting this separation
and this impossibility of life
which exists in the coveted world you
know it's like if you
if you if god and adam have gloves on
then there's no creation happening
um and so that was the problem with that
with the let's say that meme but
in terms of the ai meme it's fascinating
because it has to do with some of the
things that i've been talking about in
terms of the system of the beast
where in the totalizing system in the
desire to be
at the top and not have anything above
us right in the desire to kind of have
this revolt against
against the divine or revolt against the
spiritual world
uh there is it's there's a there's a
story which makes it inevitable that at
some point we're going to want to create
life because we have to claim for
ourselves
all the things that were above us we
have to take the crown for ourselves put
it on our head
and so there's like an inevitable story
which will happen
and it is this you know the metropolis
uh um
the this this whole idea of the creation
of an artificial being it's just
something that
was there and was there in the fiction
from the very beginning of the modern
age and it's
it just kind of carried through until
today so
yeah well isn't it isn't it also there
in in genesis when eve
gives birth to cain and says i have
created a man
i think no she says god has given me god
has given me
uh a man i think is what she is what she
says
it's more it's more it's more like uh
it's more the story of the these
artificial beings in the sense of
making these idols that in the scripture
that's what will become this image of uh
creating an artificial being which then
becomes the center of a community
so it's like a statue of of a god or of
a person
and we breathe we breathe uh in its
nostrils and then it becomes
it becomes like the vehicle for the god
let's say the shell
in which the god inhabits yes yes
yeah actually actually i was just
listening to a podcast that suggested
that
actually that wasn't what hebrew means
but that's a
that's a that's another discussion what
do you mean sorry but
that's it that said that actually the
hebrew should really be translated so
that he was making that claim
oh really interesting yeah interesting i
mean that that
that that then i mean it would be
interesting to think about the
differences for sure
uh because like a good example would be
uh lilith
so the let's say the the mythology the
mythology around lilith has to do with
this
so lilith actually spawns
children from herself without the seed
of adam
uh and so she ends up spawning these
different monsters
and so there is this desire to let's say
contain
not being not have this normal
complementary union between heaven and
earth but try to kind of contain
wherever you are as a totality and then
try to spawn children
out of that totality and so the the
legend of lilith certainly has that
imagery and that's why
what she ends up creating are monsters
and so the image of like
of lilith producing monsters is the same
story as frankenstein it's the
it's the the problem of the the pride of
frankenstein
who wants to to take the crown of god on
himself
and then ends up making a monster um and
so you see that there's
there are a lot of tropes there are a
lot of those tropes like that the matrix
all of these stories end up falling into
this kind of pattern almost inevitably
yes yeah yes so so would that be
something like the difference between
whether or not
so there's a debate in ai round about
whether or not we're creating something
which is a tool that will that we'll be
using with us or whether we're going to
be creating something that's going to be
completely
autonomous to us and maybe been equal to
us
or or actually this is one this is one
of the things where in the ai meme
um it's quite often swapped from one
side to the other so that it's easy to
replace one one to the other so
uh in the ai in the ai um world
there's of course lots of debate and
speculation about whether or not ai is
going to be superior to us
in lots of ways yeah there's that will
definitely happen
and then that this is what we talked
about before this idea of
creating the body for a god um and it
seems like
that's that seems to be mostly what's
what's happening and it's also
one of the the things is that it's it it
all makes sense in terms of
understanding
the scientific approach to reality
because in
let's say in the kind of materialistic
approach to reality we
value quantification right we value
quantity we value
quantity of information we think that
quantity of information uh
and let's say quantifiable phenomena
is actually superior or is the origin of
spiritual
truth or of of of uh patterns and so
because of that
then it ends up coming it's almost like
if because we noticed that ai will have
more power in terms of capacity to
calculate
capacity to gather information then
because our value system is already
upside down
then we will necessarily see that ai
as as a king because we already think
that that's where
reality is and so if we have a being
that can calculate
faster than us and that can gather more
information than us
then we we will ultimately think that
that's what superiority is
yeah yeah because i think one of the
things that one of the things we have to
be really careful with technology
over and over and over again and
especially actually
when you examine it a lot but you we end
up being kind of entranced by the
technology
by what it can do but then we start
thinking about what its goals are and
also what its strengths are and then
when we look back at humans
we measure humans by the same goals and
strengths so what you said in terms of
like quantity and quantification
um exactly and i mean the modern world
has basically
it really is this upside down thing
where we wanted if you look at
the development of industrial
civilization there really was the desire
to
transform humans into machines you know
we wanted the factory workers the
ultimate example of that where
we just want human machines right we we
want humans that can just do things
repetitively and
and uh and like machines do and then
when we can get rid of the humans we
will right as soon as we can get rid of
the humans
we will get rid of them because that's
what we we value we value this
capacity to be efficient this capacity
to to to
to produce things uh you know and it's a
misunderstanding of what first of all
the human is and it's a misunderstanding
of the normal hierarchy of values
but this is another thing we talked
about last time which is important to
understand
is that there are a few people there are
some people that unders that know that
or at least it seems like they know that
and so there's a there's a trick being
played there's
like cars behind their back where the
the ai
will be infused with values will be
infused with an ideology
and and and but it'll be presented just
as this powerful computer
but it will have and you can see it
right now right we see it with google
how they're framing reality how they're
you know uh giving
precedent to certain search terms and
they're controlling the search
you can see that it's actually a
value-laden phenomena but that
they tried to hide it almost as if they
they know that we think the
quantification is the real
is the most important thing so let's
hide the value so that people can't see
what we're doing
it's like it is like a card trick yes
yes it is and
and those notions of efficiency and
speed
i mean so the way in which i mean i have
another whole another whole topic but
uh the discussion goes along for a pace
so maybe just
not go down just there's more we can say
about the memes but
the way in which intelligence is thought
of in relation to ai is such a narrow
way of thinking about it
but also part and parcel of intelligence
is speed so like when you lie q test
part and parcel of it
is how quickly you do it um and
and and how efficiently you are and
whether or not you're exactly the same
exactly the same answer that's the way
which comes into factory working
so but if you go going back to the use
of the vatican using
these kinds of these kinds of memes in
relation to a health conference and of
course innocence of like if you're in a
hospital you want things to be efficient
to a certain degree but so many problems
get caused by the goals of
efficiency efficiency and health um and
trying to trying to do things really
really
you know really really quickly and
speedily it's not this is a way
in which to sort of to heal people i
mean
you're going back to the vatican being
about wearing wearing those
gloves you would ordinarily the first
thing you would think of
but first thing you'd think of in terms
of health
in terms of two hands touching but to me
the healing power of touch
and if you're wearing rubber gloves you
can't you're not touching the person are
you but
like you know like you know premature
babies will thrive if they need skin
skin contact but you know it happens
throughout the whole life you need the
healing power of touch
so yeah well it's contraceptive culture
we we we think we don't realize because
we we
let's say we've reduced we we've reduced
reality it's a very very specific thing
and we don't realize that what
the even the even the notion of
contraceptive as
a as a let's say a factor in in society
right as a part of the story
what it does in terms of understanding
what productive human
relationships are you know that it it's
not you know it never
it won't end up being just about sex
it'll end up flowing out into because
sexuality is such a it's such a deep
part of our narrative like it's such a
deep part of
understanding who we are and how bonds
are created in society
that when you fiddle with that you're
gonna end up
yeah you're gonna end up with an image
of god and man wearing rubber gloves and
not
and not seeing what's going on like not
understanding why
it's actually uh it's actually
preventing contact it's actually
preventing real
productive relationships so yeah yeah
it's like
i mean it's interesting in relation to
responses for pandemic this notion of
hygiene and the idea that you've got to
have
completely separate ourselves off and
have all these boundaries around
ourselves so i think that maybe
this is a really complex topic but i
think it might be related to where
there's been such a push
towards vaccines rather than rather than
thinking about
rather than thinking about um treatments
the vaccine seems to be pushed far far
more as if the idea is that the vaccine
is shielding us
and the germs will never end never enter
us as if we got to keep up
absolute purity yeah but also because
they figured out a way because they used
to they made
before that you would have a vaccine and
then that was it uh and that's no good
like that's not good for the business
so now they found a way to have vaccines
that you have to take again
so it's like okay well now vaccines are
great because you have to update your
vaccine
every like six months or whatever so
it's perfect right so
it's a good solution now yeah yeah and
now you don't have to
now everybody has to take it so
everybody has to take the vaccine
and everybody has to update it every
several months and so
it ends up being this interesting it
also ends up being the strange communal
thing
the the the whole aesthetics around the
vaccine are so
fascinating you know because they end up
almost being like uh
because all because it's painful i think
that's part of why
there's something religious about the
vaccine which is coming up and the way
people talk about it
uh as almost this um this initiation
ritual i guess i don't know how else to
to say it where
they they show pictures of themselves
with like a band-aid and
and there's this whole kind of
celebration of uh
of getting the jab um and the pain it's
almost like a little sacrifice that you
have to make for all of society where
you get the jab and then you
you're actually doing it not just for
yourself but for everybody else um and
so there's definitely like a religious
undertone to this whole the whole
aesthetic of the vaccine which is
not so surprising but slightly
disturbing i would say yeah it is
so so many people are posting on social
media that they've had it and so on but
there's also i mean i've also noticed
something else in relation to how people
talk about the vaccine
here i don't know if it's the same in
canada it's talked in terms of when
they've had the vaccine how efficient it
was and how clean it was
they went into the center and they were
out again five minutes later
so so so in terms of it like this this
drive for efficiency is
like a literally like a production
machine of people just walking in and
getting
getting jabbed and walking out again so
it kind of also suggests that they
didn't read the patient information
leaflet or maybe you weren't even given
one
i'm sure they didn't i'm sure no one has
uh you know because
this has been the big thing from the
beginning i've been also trying to help
people
understand that that ultimately it's
about trust all of this is about trust
it's not about a vaccine it's not about
what's
it's about whether or not we trust the
the authorities whether that we trust
what's going on whether or not we trust
the reason why
things are happening and this has and so
it's not about science
it's very little about science let's say
people who are doubtful suspicious
um and then the way that the way that
those who are kind of on board then
treat those that are doppler and
suspicious it's mostly about
about trust and about a vision of what
it means to
to be together and so this vaccine has
become the means by which we show that
we're part of society
uh whether or not it ends up leading to
an explicit
kind of tracing mechanism but even in
the narrative that you see
it's it's about showing that you're part
of society by getting this
this thing yeah i mean i'm just
i've just started i've just had the
thought i wonder because we've been so
isolated for the last year
more than a year now isn't it maybe
we're so so craving some kind of
connection and some kind of way of
showing that we're
connected to people but but maybe that's
one of the factors behind
oh for sure that's for certain for
certain and
oh it's also that it's a longer story
than that it's the the story of
running out of reasons why we are
together and that's part of
why the world is kind of breaking down
you know
look we need reasons to to know that
we're that we're a society
so but those you used to have
celebrations we used to have
you know religious unity or religious
ways of understanding that we're
together under god or
different ways of stating that but now
we're running out of those and so
and in a world where they're trying to
create post-national identities
then we also have a problem which is
that how do we
so they tried things like you know the
environment we're gonna fight you know
we're all gonna join together and like
fight against environmental problems but
it's not working like because it's
so abstract and it's so it does involve
sacrifice it makes you sacrifice things
and
you know you have your bins so you can
you can kind of have this liturgical
practice of like separating the trash
but it's not enough i don't think it's
an i don't think the vaccine is enough
either
but it's like they're looking for ways
to to unite people like racism
and now this is a the medical one what's
great about is that
it's trying to portray itself as
non-ideological so you can't you're not
supposed to be able to argue against it
because it's really is this kind of
objective thing where we all unite
and show that we're together by
participating in this story
so yeah you've talked you've talked
again this is going this is going
in a different direction as well because
you've talked before about problems with
culture and
lack of participation like losing losing
things so
i mean lots of things have been happened
happening i've lost in my lifetime so
there used to be
when i was at school we used to do
country dance festivals and they'd
be that's that's all gone and to be made
carnivals
i don't know if that's gone they used to
be carnivals all the time they've
they've kind of vanished
um but i also think one of the reasons
so you've talked about
this this is going off at a tangent does
it matter but you
i've heard you talk before about say
like going along to a music concert and
just sitting there as
an as an audience and that kind of being
a problem because it's not really
i see this kind of related to the
question you just had
you're totally right because one of the
things that they've tried to do
especially in the united states uh i
don't know in europe but in the united
states
for sure in the like 70s 80s all of this
they tried to unite people under
entertainment
and so there was this idea in the water
cooler conversation i don't know if you
remember when people were talking about
that
where this idea that you watch a show in
the evening and then the next day you go
to work
then everybody gets together during
break and talks about what happened on
the show
like seinfeld was one of those those
things where people had this sense that
it was somehow uniting society together
because it was creating this common this
common story that we could all attend to
and then
talk about the next day but it's not
enough right it's not enough because
it's not participative
so we need participative stories yeah
and that's why
what's coming up now is more the whole
question of
of racism uh is like because that's a
story you can
you can be a character in and you can
play a role in
and then also then again now and now
this whole medical
question and the getting the jab and you
and making doing these measures washing
your you know putting on the purell when
you go into the store
all of these kind of liturgical means
measures are there to
to be have a more participative uh
narrative
and i don't and i'm not saying that
everybody's it's like you don't
necessarily even have to think of it in
terms of conspiratorial
uh behavior where there's someone
controlling this and
forcing it to happen this way it's just
people need this
and so when it appears in front of them
like when it when it manifests
itself they're naturally going to
gravitate towards it because
because we need this type of
participation yes yes yes yeah and i
suppose
a racism one has got a bit of a problem
in terms of participation because people
are assigned roles against their often
against their will
so yeah so but so but a lot of people
are getting you know
getting really annoyed about being told
because because of
something extraneous about you you
therefore think this or
yeah it's a dangerous it's a dangerous
game to play you know it's a definitely
a dangerous game to play because it
it's actually separating us into clans
again
uh and so that's that's a scary thing
you know what
it seems like it's possible that it's
it's separating us into clans
in order for something else to come in
the whole divide and conquer
strategy where something else will come
and then unite and the medical
the medical one is like i said it's
perfect because it it's supposed to be
not non-ideological
yes yeah yes and i i'm sorry so one of
the many problems with the racism one is
that the people who are
uh most liable to be attacked of
the very people who are so free so for
example
i won't give any details but i mean a
friend of a friend was telling you
something that happened to a friend of
hers recently
and the sort of people who are getting
into trouble are precisely the kind of
people who are
say maybe working with diverse groups
trying to promote equity
trying to do social work amongst certain
people and so on and then
maybe just accused of not using the
right words
so for people who are getting into
trouble are the people who actually have
spent all their lives
trying to uh improve the quality those
kinds of things so i just think
but that's that's those suppose but they
know for a fact that they're not fair
but they're trying to do something to
help and everyone's of course who have
been getting into trouble because they
have to
you know so recently about happening
about two or three weeks ago
in britain we were told that the acronym
that had been used was being
bit black and asian minority ethnic i
think
if we told them not allowed to use it
anymore as to what we are supposed to
say so
those kinds of things are happening with
such rapidity but it's really quickly
breaking down and just making lots of
people get yeah
it's funny because it's it's one of
those things where
if we only had a normal like
acknowledgment of reality
which is that like a good example is
let's say we can use we use one where
it's like if you have a physical
handicap right if you have a physical
handicap then you are necessarily going
to be
a marginal part of society
and that has negative aspects and
positive aspects
and so it's if you try to if you realize
that a word is a is you're using
and that it's referring to the negative
aspects and then you change the word to
something else
you're going to have a problem because
if the negative aspects are going to
come back because the negative aspects
are there
and it's the same with being a minority
in general when you're a minority in a
group it doesn't matter
what it's not has nothing to do with
race or whatever if you're a minority in
a group then you are
necessarily going to struggle to find
your place in that group whether it's
any type of of of group um and so
and so instead of just realizing that
this is a normal thing
and we need to try to palliate for it
and try to make it
as as good as we can and try to help
people integrate as much as possible
if we keep just playing this weird
semantic game then it's
whatever word you use to talk about a
minority is going to have negative
undertones because it's hard to be a
minority
and so you can't avoid it it's going to
keep coming back
yes yes yeah yes it's just it's just
this ignoring of how
of how uh of how reality works i think
you know and
a desire to kind of impose this weird
yes this weird system which actually
doesn't
doesn't pan out in the world
yeah but but though so i'm so one of the
things i think is really really neat to
stress and thinking about what
technology is doing is it's never just
for technology
it's never just a technology it's always
the culture behind it and
they're often working in synergy or or
um the technology event
is helping to shape the culture and
there's like a really complex
interaction between
the two and that happens in relation to
how we think about health
for example about about the ways in
which
um technology might open up
possibilities with with
health and that changes how we think of
it so actually so for example
i mean in relation in relation to the
pandemic um
the expectation for expectation for how
long we should live has changed so
rapidly
so i looked up some charts just just
last week life expectancy of a developed
world
or life expectancy in general has
shifted but like expect to see in the uk
which i presume is similar to canada has
increased by nearly three years in the
last decade
it's just astonishing and and so
our expectations of of what we expect
out of health
it's no it's it's it's changed
everything
and like you said and and so
even even this is this is this might be
very controversial but
i get a sense that for example when you
look at kobe deaths in different
countries and everything
i always wonder if it's if it's more a
comment
on the state let's say of the society
itself
pre-pandemic rather than about the
disease and so
you know if there was if there was a
country where the the population was
extremely old and that the systems to to
to say to to deal or to to live with
these elderly people was not
healthy then i think that's what
happened here in quebec we have the
highest one of the highest rates of
death
in canada and almost in the world in
terms of percentage and people are like
oh we're hit hard we're hit hard but i'm
like i'm not sure it's
hit hard i think there's something else
going on there's it's more a story about
how
of how the elderly exists and how like
you said the expectations we've had
which is that
the idea of dying at 70 you know when i
was young was like hey
that's that's not bad but now dying at
70 is almost like a scandal like you
can't die at 70.
yes yeah yes yeah yeah it's yeah it's
really really interesting yeah
and so it's actually changed the the
story uh maybe you can talk a little bit
about that because i
i know you you were thinking about the
idea of how
one of the things it does like
technology offers up these these
possibilities and then
that possibility will affect the way the
story lays itself out
yes yeah it really does so so i don't
listen to your monk your monkey man
video
last week the monkey monkey man yeah
like i was just so interested in that i
i i looked i read it i looked at the
actual paper
um i didn't read all of it because it's
like pages and pages of really technical
stuff
but it's it's got something in it that
you um you see over and over and over
again
so in the summary um it talks about
intersperi into species chimera
formation i've got it here
with human pluripotent stem cells this
represents a necessary alternative
it's so it's presented as being
necessary
so it's research is being presented as
necessary necessary to what
so it's an instrumental rationality it's
necessary to certain
aims that you have so you know
what do they say do they tell us what
the aims are do they mention them you
know
so so so there are various regenerative
medicine applications so for example
um including like the generation of
organs and tissues for transplantation
and also just understanding early human
development and
early embryo development in humans and
also evolution evolution of humans and
of primates so so one sort of fairly
abstract knowledge i mean the abstract
knowledge to be
perfectly fair a lot of knowledge which
is called like blue skies research
ends up being uh really useful but also
just fascinating i mean like
stories about human evolution finding
out about human evolution is just really
it's just really interesting um but it's
always presented as being necessary if
there's a way of finding something out
the only way you can do it is is is in
this kind of way but i mean
so but if you'd murdered somebody for
example it would be necessary to find a
way to dispose of a body
to make certain
you probably shouldn't have murdered
them so it depends what it depends what
the goal our
goals is but that word necessary is just
it's just
so often slipped in something that we
just have had to do
and and it also describes it as
fundamental research
so talking about it as fundamental
research again emphasizes the notion
that it's just really
really important to do but that i was
fascinated in terms of how so there's
ways in which this idea of
necessity is opened up in terms of
possibilities but created
so that it's it's it's trying to think
up or
trying to produce like maybe organs and
transplant
so we already actually pick pig valves
are often used in transplant for heart
valve operations
humans often have pig valves planted
into them so
there's a possibility that you might be
maybe able to grow organs in other
species or
or somehow use cross-species organs so
in research they've tried to do
so basically in research they took human
stem cells so a stent just to remind
everybody a stem cell
it will come from a stem cell line grown
in a lab
a stem cell is a stem that's got the
capacity to become any different type of
cell so it could be placed in the body
and they've managed to get got these
monkey
monkey embryos so in terms of getting a
monkey embryos
that means that they've had to get the
egg and the sperm from the monkeys
which means that the female monkey has
had to um super ovulate and have the
eggs harvested
which is i mean it's quite a burden on
the monkey actually because
the women who've gone through that for
ivf it's quite a burdensome procedure
actually
um so then they've fertilize the monkey
embryos and then
in and then inject got them in a in a
stem cell
yeah they got a human stem cell and put
it into the
monkey embryo to see how many days it
can survive
and then they haven't transplanted it
into an animal but
if they were to do so it would remain an
open question as to what would happen
for human stem cells what would it do
would it develop into a particular organ
so i suppose the worst nightmare would
be but like it's a monkey body and a
human brain
yeah so it's that kind of problem but
the idea that it's necessary because we
need it for organs for transplant it's
really interesting how that kind of
necessity starts to develop
so the first the first organ transplant
patient
was somebody who happened to have an
identical twin so who knew whose kidneys
had packed in and he
needed a kidney trance well needed a
kidney transpl transplant
that was the only possibility um and he
had an identical twin so you can
transplant
from identical twin because there's
there's not going to be any organ
rejection yeah it's
exactly the same so from then organs
then spread out to close relatives
as long as they're a match and then to
finding searches
with strain with strangers um and then
it's also spread out more to sort of
black markets in organs actually
um and and and people being um accounts
of people being kidnapped and
yeah and then and then the search so
what happens is the class of patients
who could benefit from an organ
transplant
is vastly greater than the supply of
organs yeah
that's already set up a kind of
shortfall so you've created a
possibility create a possibility
in medicine we think we can do this and
then
lots of people could benefit from this
very vaguely described possibility
and then because it's a medical need so
it's also really important to understand
you could think of it in terms of a mad
scientist in a lab
like some crazy scientists doing this
stuff you can imagine you can easily
imagine the scientists doing this must
be
kind of really crazy mad
driven by lust for power yeah you see in
medicine
it's also really important but one of
the major
factors behind this is compassion yeah
and who's sick
yeah and the one thing you always have
to remember in this story is that you're
gonna die
like i'm gonna die you're gonna die
we're all gonna die okay so that's
that's that's gonna happen so like you
said so now the problem is that
is rather when am i going to die and
what is the net what is the limit
that i'm which that i'm willing to
accept that that death is reasonable
right and so with medicine what's
happened is that
we've without necessarily understanding
the ramifications of that
we're pushed the limit of what is
reasonable reason to die
further and further to a point where
like you said
they're doing these things and they're
saying it's necessary
because we've already accepted a limit
yes
what it means for a death to be
reasonable and that limit is
is so far that we're willing to do other
things which can be questionable
in order to satisfy that that that limit
and
it has a great it has a great
application to cope with
which is that we know we can
let's say they think that medically we
can contain this thing
somehow yes because it's possible we
think it's possible and because
technology makes it possible
then it's there no even question whether
we should do it or not
whether we should how far we should go
there's no limit to how far we should go
because once you've created that
possibility and because like you said
it's
motivated by compassion yes uh then it's
like this strange parasitic story
comes in and people just stop
thinking and stop asking that stop
noticing that there's actually a
competing set of values that
have to be thought of they just see the
possibility and they just embody it kind
of jump into it
yeah and this happens all the time with
tech with technology
but but certain values come to before
and it tends to be values that you can
count
so but in terms of health of course
count you can count the number of years
and how
you know how long you are alive the
things that you can more easily
account i mean it happens within the
healthcare system um
in terms of like efficiency of goals of
target
because of course one of the other
terrible things that's happening is that
people are living longer and longer
and longer but the quality of care for
elderly people is absolutely atrocious
it's just absolutely absolutely abysmal
so that's it's really interesting how i
think one movement one of the things
we're faced with
got lots and lots of examples of this
but one of the things we're faced
with is how the technology is making
different values come of
um kind of like clash with each other
or produce paradoxes so he i mean here's
one whole set of paradoxes in
i'm not what is i don't know i don't
know if paradox is the right word
but but but but certainly um
so one one of the ways in which medicine
has
has has gone down the route actually i
want to get back to talking about
the monkey embryos in in a minute but
one of the ways in which it produces a
kind of cloud the sort of a clash
but you tell me whether it's the right
word would be through
genetic technology which is developed
techniques
for screening before either within uh
testing out testing embryos in the womb
and maybe having selective termination
of pregnancy
for various damaged ones or pre-op
implantation diagnosis
severe tooth for lots and lots of
different diseases really commonly as
for many pregnant women will be screened
for down syndrome
at the same time there are other people
putting in lots and lots of work
for to treat the very same diseases
so cystic fibrosis for example which is
quite
quite a common genetic disease among
certain populations
it's quite a pretty serious disease but
the treatment for that is improving
really really really
really quite well and down syndrome i
think is a really
important example because at the same
time as screening for dancing was being
pushed
so i i believe that iceland is is is
hoping to have
like zero down syndrome births um at the
same time
people with down syndrome are living
longer and longer and longer they're um
going to school they go to university
they're holding down jobs they're
getting married but the possibilities of
the life of somebody with down syndrome
is um in increasing really quite
significantly
people with down syndrome are being used
in adverts so
it it it's different strands yeah
there's a major clash like
there's basically a inclusion versus
eugenics clash which is
quite insane when you realize just how
extreme those two
those two things are yeah yeah yes and
yeah and and and
also so i mean so much this is gain is
also driven by uh driven by compassion
by you know feeling that that parents
would feel they wouldn't be able to cope
with certain things so again
i want to stress it's really really easy
when you're talking about these things
to make it sound as if you're being
really judgmental
so so if that's not that's not what i'm
talking about i'm not
kind of everyone's sort of it's partly
because we have such a legalistic way of
thinking about
ethics that you think if you're trying
to look at the subtlety or nuances
behind things that means
you think you're going to try and you
what you're intending to do is to stop
people from doing things yeah but we
need to be we need to be attentive to
this because let's say let's take the
monkey man
story and so this drive
to create hybrids right this drive to
and it really is a weird drive like it's
like it's
a narrative drive um the drive to create
hybrids
for medical reasons but at the same time
there is a narrative in society there's
a story
and one of those stories is the
revolutionary story
um and so if you have a revolutionary
pattern in your culture
and you create ai that revolutionary
pattern is going to
find its place in ai so we're going to
have a sense that the robots need to
free themselves from us
so if you do the same with the hybrid
you have the same problem
the recent the recent line of planet of
the apes movies
has the apes as the good guys and the
humans as the bad guys
please remember that people because as
you're creating these hybrids
and you have a revolutionary pattern in
your culture
you're setting up something that you're
not you're not going to
you're setting up a situation where
you're going to have compassion for
these hybrids
and and not you know in a com an upside
down compassion even
where you're going to want to make them
into your king which is just a scary
stuff
yeah yeah yes so so one of the things
that i've noticed
going back to the ai creation meme with
the spark of electricity
as you said i mean you pointed out that
but if it was light then that would fit
it more with the genesis story but
if we're thinking about it in terms of
electricity and we're thinking that
and of course we are made of electricity
our brains run on electricity
um but that's that's one of the ways in
which humans can be seen to be inferior
to ai
because one of the ways in which um
we're often talked of dismissively is
that because our brains are running
in violent we're
trapped if you like it's not a good way
of putting it but we are
biological beings yeah and there's a lot
of people saying well
the way in which we think if our brains
are like computers we're trapped by
what's called wet wear have you ever
um like where or what work so then the
ai
isn't it can run much faster it's in
silicon it you can have quantum
computing you could do stuff
far faster so again that's that's an
example of how we think what we've
created is going to be better than us
we're just trapped
trapped in when wet where all the way in
which of our thought process
processes are hampered if you like by
our emotions our desires or by the ways
in which actually we've stemmed from
evolution
so another way in which we're seen as
being potentially inferior to ai
is because a phrase i haven't actually
heard it until recently but
but we're just kind of like trapped in
monkey suits because of the ways in
which where
the ways in which we have you know
factors about how we behave driven by
our evolutionary past for example
yeah i guess this is like a really good
example about how we're kind of seen to
be
um we progressed beyond the monkey but
we're kind of like trapped
trapped by like taints of our monkeyness
that if only we could get away from the
monkeyness we could then go on to the
to the next step yeah that's where we
that's where you see this
this like hint of gnosticism in the
modern thinking
you know uh the idea that evolution is
progress
right first of all it's very d it's
supposedly deeply
unscientific but it seems to be a trope
that people cannot get rid of they just
keep
even the most even the most like
evolutionist if you listen to an evolut
like a
an evolutionary biologist for long
enough you're gonna
you're gonna find him falling right in
that trope even if even if
he'll say no no no evolution is in
progress they just end up getting into
that trope no matter how
they how they they do it um and so the
the image of moving from the monkey to
the computer
is definitely something which has a deep
story a deep story version like you see
it in all kinds of very uh
even popular culture and type of
thinking where you have this idea of the
the robot as being a superior form yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
so so yes so
in look in doing these monkeys these
monkey experiments
we have this is one of the ways in which
there's a form of hybridity in terms of
ways which we flip from one way of
thinking about ourselves to another way
of thinking about
ourselves so in order to do the
experiments uh
in order for it to work we had to pick a
monkey because they're closer to us
in evolutionary terms we've only
diverged from them i don't know 17
million years old
so we're quite close to quite close to
them so that's why it works so we have
to see ourselves as like biological
beings who were fairly closely related
to monkeys but they wanted to justify
doing the research on these monkeys
who are after all are quite completely
complex beings in order to justify
like taking it's worse for the female
man i mean it is actually worse for a
female monkey
because of collecting eggs is so much
more odorous in order to justify doing
it
we've got to think of ourselves as being
superior to the monkeys
because we're not we're not trying to
create organs in order to save monkey
lives
we're using monkeys to try to save human
lives we wouldn't we wouldn't sacrifice
a human
to try to save a monkey we just wouldn't
do it because we think of ourselves
but it's is so it's really interesting
so
only like about 20 years ago when we
managed a sequence of human genome
everybody was really excited and saying
at last we found the essence of man
as if our genomic code was going to be
like the book of life
people talked about that for various
reasons we don't do
talk about that anymore one of the
reasons being that when we sequenced all
the genes
it turned out that really embarrassingly
humans didn't have many genes
compared to other animals jeans is
really simple worms
and other animals have got far more than
us so that was it's really strange how
that's kind of like a bit embarrassing
and then it turns out that genes are
much more complex than we thought
but a lot of stuff is actually really
environment and
and but lots of diseases before we're
going to be able to cure is actually
much more complex
so that's all faded but this but what
one of the things that technology does
is is like it it exposes and puts
pressure
pressure on the contradictory ways in
which we think about ourselves and
evolution
i mean evolution is evolution is
the point that you're making about
evolution is is completely right it's
really hard to find anybody talking
about evolution
and not see it in terms of of progress
and it's like
so i think evolution has done this
really cunning bait and switch
on us so it
so it came along in the 19th century and
despite what anybody says
it was used to say that oh we're really
we're just like we're nothing but
monkeys yeah
all those cartoons of charles darwin
being like a monkey we're nothing like
monkeys so therefore
religion is a load of rubbish we just
evolved and it's random it's interesting
in terms of how it's now seen in terms
of progress it's just as completely
random
completely meaningless these random
mutations happened
and some of them worked and some of them
didn't and by this accidental progress
accidental i said progress by mistake
yeah
yeah little process we've done
with humans as being like the latest
thing
um but then having got rid of religion
more or less amongst people thinking
really scientifically
it's like they have to get some kind of
meaning and progress from somewhere
so the meaning and the progress comes
from evolution and so
now so the interesting really
interesting thing is instead of having a
picture before whereby
there were animals lower down and then
man in the middle
and then angels and then god you know
like
i mean one of my actually my favorite i
love psalm 8 you know the
band has you have made us man a little
lower than the angels what is man that
ma
bow art mindful of him a little lower in
the angels for dominion over the animals
so there's a huge amount of fuss for
people saying this religious view is
awful
how dare you think you've got to minion
over the animals yeah
how dare you think so and what that's
been replaced by
it's by um i blame it all on john lennon
actually
his song imagine yeah
there's no heaven above us only sky so
the if above us is only sky
that means that we're at the top that's
right yeah we're at the top and
and it plays out in so many interesting
and and uh let's say
like you said kind of this contradictory
way would end up showing the same
reality which is that
even the idea of environmentalism is so
powerful because
it's all the environmentalists say how
arrogant you know man is so arrogant
because he places himself
above uh above nature and tries to
control nature
he's like would you tell an ant that
like would you tell an ant that it that
it's tried to control nature
no you you the only reason why you say
that because you do believe that you are
above nature
and you do believe that you're going to
save the environment you know and that
and that by acting like a human does
you're going to undo the bad things that
other humans did
and so you can't get out of it it just
even in those that are the most
anti-human kind of pro-environment uh
thinking they end up putting human
beings at the top you
just it just happens on its own it's
it's actually quite funny to
to pay attention to yes yeah because in
terms of environmentalism if you just
see us
as organisms part of a planet if you
take something like a guy a hypothesis
then if if for example we lead we we do
stuff that leads to human extinction
through
climate change or whatever we're doing
but we'll just die out and the
cockroaches will take over and stuff
that's right is there morality to like
uh the the
meteorite that destroyed the dinosaurs
like why would there be more morality
in human extinction or not just human
extinction all the other races that are
being
extinct like if uh like if if a certain
predator
like eats away eats all its prey and
then it does it
to an extent that it can't survive
itself that's no moral question
it just happened and then other beings
will take its place and
just keep going and so nobody believed
that like nobody
everybody believes that we are like
little gods
uh you know on the in the world it's
just that whether or not this little god
has ultimate power or whether or not it
should be submitted to a higher
a higher truth that's that ends up being
the
the question and there's a kind of
unconsciousness about
so many of these of these movements and
these
especially environmentalism is the one
that is the most to me
like contradict it's like i i agree that
we should take care of the
of the world around us like i don't
think we think what we're doing is that
it's abusive
but i think i think that there's a
blindness which means that you're
gonna struggle to get there because you
don't see what's really happening
oh right right yes yes okay
um and so the monkey man is definitely
something that we
we need to pay attention to in terms of
the question of hybridity and the idea
of the human
uh computer hybrid is also something
which is definitely
at the same time on the on the four
let's say with elon musk and his
his microchips in the brain so i don't
know if you thought a little bit about
that and
the stories that are surrounding that
kind of thinking right yes yes yes well
because because that is that's
that's linked to a notion of progress so
if if we're so if you take if you take
this the view that like
some ways of thinking about how humans
are the pinnacle of evolution
um of course the problem of matters if
you're if you're thinking that evolution
is a pr is a prime
mover when you read it you just wait and
see what evolves next
but actually people are not really
satisfied with that so there's kind of
if you like well a number of different
strands forward but you could divide
them into two one is
one is a kind of strand humans need to
need to use machinery to try to improve
to try to improve ourselves so we have
the elon musk type of wanting to have
the neural link implant in the brain
so one of the reasons why he wants to do
that is to make us able to keep up with
ai
because thinking that ai is going to be
basically thinking so fast that we won't
be able to understand it so we need to
be able to link with ai to to won't be
to unders understand it
so merge having these um plates in your
brain
i mean i i don't think i would volunteer
for that
but actually that's also really
interesting because it's also really
interesting it actually
relates again back to that question of
medicine in terms of developing it
because a proposed use for it would be
for people who are maybe
completely paralyzed to be paralyzed in
some terrible accident
who might be actually quite grateful for
an implant in their brain so that they
can maybe directly move the world
so that you could maybe get your
thoughts translated and so on
so actually you could you could then
actually really start to understand why
if you'd had this if you were suddenly
paralyzed or you'd you know
some catastrophic medical disaster
and you were given the option but it
might be pretty dangerous but would you
like an implant in your head so that you
can then communicate and it's
got locked in synchro you can you can
actually understand why
somebody might think that would be you
know a really good progress for somebody
but um in terms of understanding
in terms of taking upon that risk in
order to communicate with ai
one of the things that's happening is
that it's thinking of progress
in terms of something really quite
specific so that
people who talk about progress in this
way there are people who so max
tegmark for example um who's um he's a
cosmologist
um i think he's at mit and he was one of
the people who's
he's one of the founders of the future
of life institute and he wrote a book
about three years ago i think called
um i think i think it's called human 3.0
i sometimes yeah it's human 3.0 i
suggested you read it i want but i know
you have enough time to read it
so he talks about evolution he's an
example of people talking about
evolution
but seeing evolution in terms of um
making the universe aware of itself and
having knowledge and understanding and
seeing it in terms of facts
that's a good thing so he said before
that happened before the universe woke
up
there was no value in the world you have
to wake up in order
you have consciousness of yourself and
that would create knowledge and value
but then humans are at the pinnacle of
that but we've reached
the end of more or less the end of it in
terms of biblical evolution is going to
be too slow
i'm stephen hawking talked about that as
well he said human biological evolution
is so slow so we're going to get
overtaken by machines
so you might worry that your machines
are overtaking us or you might be
pleased because you might think what we
can do is
invent machines and they'll be more
intelligent and we'll create more and
more and more intelligence in the
universe
and that's where the future is the
future is not human so one future is
humans we need to enhance ourselves to
survive or to develop and the other is
that
bye bye little human you were just like
the monkey ancestor
um you were just like the neanderthal to
the um to the ai
and the future of descendants are going
to be ai but of course
in order to paint that picture you have
to decide what out of
what's happening in evolution is is
progress yeah what's up progress
constitutes intelligence and that is
yeah
so like you know so if we go back to the
creation of adam meme if you think of it
man is made in the image of in the image
of god
you didn't have to think about well what
aspects of you know what aspects of us
are in the image of god it can't be
every little tiny detail
what is it so the answer these people
are giving is that it's
intelligence this particular a
particular form of intelligence which
you think a machine can exemplify
yeah exactly and i think i think that
one of the issues
that happens is of course understanding
yourself as the summit of
as the human person that says the summit
of uh of this
capacity to value is already it's
already the problem like it's already
the problem because
the mechanism of valuing or the capacity
to notice the good
is something which at least in every
other culture in the whole history of
the universe has helped people
understand that there's actually a
hierarchy that goes up
above us that this valuing actually
leads up to goods
which are beyond just the individual
person whether it be
communal bodies you know in terms of
of beings that come together and in in
systems that point to something above it
and then
continuing on into seeing these values
embodied in different
images of gods or angels all the way up
to the infinite
but as soon as you see the the human
person as
this only valuing thing in the in the in
reality
then it leads to this problem of
the solipsistic problem of this this
kind of uh
like because they become self-valuing
like at this weird self-valuing and then
it creates
these strange aberrations which are
both extremes in a way that are that are
kind of too extreme
in terms of like you said uh seeing
ourselves as these all powerful gods
that can do whatever or seeing ourselves
as these
future ants which will spawn something
above us which will be something that is
more reasonable
that is faster that is more that is more
in terms of quantifiable
uh qualities has more in terms of these
kind of quantifiable qualities but
valuing is the
is not quantifiable like that's what
valuing is value is
quality it's something which jumps above
this quantifiable or this speed or all
of this
of this type of thing that people think
is what intelligence is
and so there's an internal problem even
in the way that they
that they understand uh what
intelligence is what the purpose
you know what the purpose of of
consciousness is all of this is
deeply problematic yes
yes yeah i think you're right but there
are more problems still so i think one
of the problems
i think one of the things we as humans
always have to do in terms of thinking
about value
is always be aware that we might be
wrong and to serve
and to ask ourselves the question and so
that's why it's a dangerous just to do
it on your own that's why
you might you need feedback from other
people that's why you always have to
you know ask yourself whether you know
whether or not you're
you're biased in some way you ask
yourself whether or not you're being
selfish
um actually i did my i mean this is
something else i've always been really
interested in i did my phd on
self-deception
we always have to be aware of the fact
that we might be you know but we might
be deluding ourselves in some kind of
way so we need we need to have some a
certain sort of humility
but you just don't you just don't see
that in these grand
in these grand visions and something
else also that's happening is that
there's so much focus on the individual
self there's so much focus on being
on the individual so of course the
individual is really important but you
can focus on it
on it too much but there's focus on the
individual at the same
time and so absolute certainty that
these people are absolutely certain that
they know
how to solve problems so like so for
example the um
in terms of like the of climate change
the hubris of people who think okay
we're going to block out the sun now
that's insane that that that i can't
when i see that i think i'm in a science
fiction movie
these people are not they they don't
exist like this there's no way that
someone is actually saying that it's
like a
like in the simpsons they had that idea
like blocking off the sun
at some point the the mr burns wanted to
block off the sun
like crazy i know i know it's not even
like a
science fiction music like a bad austin
powers movies like
like it's just insane so so there's but
the level of humor but that the
certainty about the
but the individual is right when they're
focusing so much on this narrow goal
but the individual self is being uh sort
of
emphasized so much at a time when
actually in so many ways
the technology that we're using is
destroying the individual self
it's creating so much uncertainty it's
there's so many there are so many ways
in which human
human beings are constructed income
where complex and where
in a sense inherently provoke in we've
got parts of us which are
prone to divide in various ways so you
can have emotions
which can be at odds with what we know
about things
we've got different aspects to ourselves
we've got an inner subjective part
we've got an outer objective part
um our emotions can be um don't have
desires which can be in conflict
and i think one of the things that the
technology we have is doing at the
moment
is in so many different instances over
and over and over again it's emphasizing
certain aspects of ourselves
and it's manipulating us in ways that
creates division within ourselves
which is manipulating our desires and
it's manipulating our relationships with
ourselves
and relationships with other people so
it's cheap so as for example we talked
like before last time about
online meetings and talking of the zoom
it changes how we see ourselves because
we're looking at we can see an image of
ourselves all the time so it's changing
our self-perception
it's changing how we relate to other
people oh actually actually i should
just mention
in relation to since we talked last time
about how odd it is relating to somebody
over zoom
and because you're just relating really
really remotely i've got a new strategy
for my zoom
meetings which is that i'm in the same
room as i was last time but i've turned
the table around
because and now i've told itself i'm
facing the person
so my computer is i'm facing montreal so
i looked it up on the map it's a little
it's a little gesture to remind yourself
that i'm an embodied person somewhere
yeah i'm talking to some friends in
australia tomorrow so i've got the face
in that direction
so that's a lot of that that's my my
little rebellion again it's a but
it's it's it seems it could seem like
it's not much but it's a little
just even the idea of attending and
having something in memory like this a
gesture to just turn your table
is recognizing something and recognizing
the the difficulty of the situation
let's say
um and so it's not a it's not a bad idea
because if the person isn't in your
screen right
and that's a that that's something that
we will alter
we we tend to default to even if we
don't think of it rationally but we tend
to act that way
and uh and think that way so so yeah
listen paula we've been going for a
while and i think that we could probably
just
keep talking forever and so i think this
is definitely going to uh
going to ask for another conversation uh
sooner than later
and and a lot of people are interested
in
understanding what's going on and
understanding the the stories that go
with the technology
and the contradictions and and these
competing narratives in terms of
who we are and what we're doing in the
time of covid and with all these new
technologies on the horizon as well so
i really appreciate you uh taking the
time with us
to to work through this and and uh you
know and be willing to
kind of put ourselves out and put
yourself out on a limb to to talk about
difficult things that that have a lot of
implications so thanks a lot
well thank you thank you i really i
really enjoyed it and as you said yeah
as there's loads more that we could that
we could talk about
definitely and we will that's for sure
so everybody thank you
for your attention um we really
appreciate it of course
there's we talk we've touched on so many
things so definitely
go at it in the comment section and uh
get involved in the discussion there
there uh you know we talk you know we
we just like paula and i just like you
we're overwhelmed by what we're seeing
and we're overwhelmed by
by noticing what's happening and so we
we need to
to be all of us kind of working together
and seeing how we can
find little solutions and bigger
solutions to
the difficulties that that this
situation is bringing to us so thanks
for attention everybody and i'll talk to
you very soon